physics itself is not view price Society
highly and so if you look at medicine
all these other issues that they will
say this is why women don't want to do
physics would have been true in medicine
as well and yet now more women go to
Medicine than men parents still sell
children that are good and sides become
doctors if they're good on the Arts to
become lawyers maybe now there's some
computer science because there's so much
money in that and this is how Society
values things it's with money if you get
paid really well the society is really
saying we value this physics is not one
of those value thing so it's a rare
thing doesn't matter if you're a man or
a woman until society says this is
something to do I find it very strange
to say why don't women want to do it
well the B don't want to do it